let's see if we can compare the fraction
5/3 to 10/7 soar which if we can figure
out which one of these fractions is
larger and you might notice both of
these are larger than a whole a whole
would be 3/3 this is 5/3 and a whole
here would be 7 7 so this is 10 7s so
which of these is going to be larger to
help us with that I'm going to plot each
of these on a number line and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try to do the same before I work it out
all right so I have a number line here
we have 0 1 2 and first I divide the
number line in 2/3 you see it right over
here this is 1/3 this is 2/3 the the
thirds the thirds are being marked off
in blue right over here you see that
each from the space from 0 to 1 is split
into three equal sections 1 2 3 and then
the space from 1 to 2 is put into three
equal sections 1 2 & 3
you see that right over here so I'm
marking off I'm marking off all of the
I'm marking off all of the thirds so
this is 1/3 this is 2/3
this is 3/3 which is of course the same
thing as 1 this is 4/3 and then this
right over here is going to be 5/3 and
if we were to go over here 2 would be
the same thing as 6 thirds but we care
about is 5/3 so that's that right over
there we don't want to fill it in so
much so 5/3 5/3 is that right over there
now let's think about sevenths now to do
sevenths I have to split this the the
part of the number line between 0 & 1 or
between each whole number into 7 equal
spaces so you see that here 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 you have 7 equal sections so this is
1/7 this is 2/7 3/7 4/7 5/7 6 7 this is
7/7 I could write that down this is 1 is
the same thing as 7 7 8 7 9 7 10
sevenths right over here this right over
here is 10 over 7 so we see that both
and seven and five thirds are between
one and two but which of these is
actually larger well we see 5/3 is
further to the right on the number line
than ten sevenths let me make this a
little bit easier to see so ten sevenths
and that is right over there five thirds
is to the right of ten sevenths so 5/3
is greater than ten sevenths so how do
we write the symbol
well we always want to open it up to the
larger number 5/3 is a larger number so
we want the larger side or the opening
on the larger number or the smaller side
or this point pointing to the smaller
number so we have 5/3 is greater than
ten sevenths